[Music]
what's up guys Lauren stop in here for
the iron Lords podcast and Lords of
gaming dotnet I'm here at the
Metropolitan Pavilion play NYC and it's
my great pleasure to be back again with
our friends from Boston this is Khalil
we have Chris back there you have I met
right here these guys are decoy games
and we're looking at their inaugural
game so insanity which is on the
precipice of release so what's up back
good to see you thank you so much man
we're excited to be here so excited to
be in this huge crowd it's like the bit
the best play crafting any event of the
year so we're excited to be here so tell
me man we show you guys at PAX East we
love your game we love the vision of the
game we love just the entire howdy core
games came together right because I got
told you guys it reminds me of us and
how we came together so tell me how's
they've been since pax or later like how
close do you guys to release it so I
mean we've been really busy I could say
that we're actually full-time now
full-time developers so we're excited
about that
we left our love for our previous
full-time jobs pushing towards release
working on online play right now getting
really close basically is lining up a
bunch of stuff but we're excited we're
ready to release we're showing one of
the most complete packages of our games
today so we're showing off the Xbox
experience the PlayStation experience
and the Nintendo experience so that's
what are you right there how close we
are
amazing amazing so when you initially
spoke to us about the game one of the
things that really struck us was the
fact that it was it seemed like a very
simplistic game but then you had all of
these different modes you had a story
mode you had the versus multiplayer you
had the the the team-based multiplayer
so tell me have you guys added anything
what has been refined what what what
changes have you made since we saw you
at PAX so I'll say from the grants
perspective we probably added stuff as
we hide a lot that when you come to
conventions know what I mean so as far
as like the stuff in the game we've
already developed all that most of it's
code complete but as far as what
everyone else has seen yeah you guys
have a lot more to see than you've seen
at the convention so so tell us a little
about what you're doing at play and wise
together you have a tournament going on
they'll tell us a little ball that yeah
I mean we weren't all hot for this show
so first and foremost first-come
first-serve anyone get shark-fin hats
they're really cool we have our first
official tournament so the unleash Cup
today we have deathmatch free-for-all
tomorrow as teams
anyone can play anyone who makes it to
quarterfinals at all and on get to the
kids play on the big stage so we want to
give back to the fans a little bit slap
them and kind of take the spotlight so
for anybody who has not seen our video
and if you have and gold Lords or gaming
that met in the iron loads podcast and
check out our practices video with decoy
games tell us a little bit about the
game just generally for somebody who
doesn't know anything about the game of
course it's a four player underwater
shooter it's got competitive and
cooperative game modes or you can play
with her against your friends do it
across five different levels
the main concept of the game is that you
play this guy called a MOBA he's an
underwater underwater soldier and he has
these things called unleashes these
unleashes like special moves he can turn
to a big shark turns her piranhas
you got like a medic we have all
different like defensive and offensive
attacks this thing completely changed
the whole balance of the game this goes
across all different game modes you can
play online locally competitive
cooperative we have something for
everyone here tell you man the game
looks beautiful it looked beautiful back
at PAX East like I
I wouldn't be able to tell the
difference when I tell you this man like
like I said before we're so happy that
you guys are this close to launch that
it's just a group of three of you guys
that grew up together it's an it's an
amazing thing to be able to come
together that way and make a game I know
you guys have been working really hard
so we wish you nothing but the most
success I'll be there day one purchasing
probably on multiple platforms as well
switch to my primary you know but thank
you guys I mean tell people basically
you're looking at the end of summer do
you have a date I know you're not gonna
tell us but when you are you are you
circling around a date yeah we got a
date in house we're working towards
trying to get out there as soon as
possible most important we want to make
sure we have the best quality game for
everyone to play so that's our biggest
priority but we also want to get out
there as fast as possible so yeah we do
have a deal we're working towards still
working towards end of summer we're
excited to get out there we are pushing
as hard as we kind of get that date so
absolutely guys you heard it here first
iron Lords podcast decoy games this is
Chris we're gonna be on studio right you
guys gonna see us live you know listen
these guys will be on ILP soon we got to
talk to Cognito for the logistics and
see when it's gonna happen but most
definitely décor games will be on the
iron Lords podcast that is for sure
alright so you heard it here first later
no it's now dough lovely hat sir what
are you feeling
I really am enjoying this I mean you
have to constantly focus on all around
yourself and the controls are so fluid
it's great what do you feel about the
other power-ups and like what you're
able to do in the deathmatch I think
that the power-ups actually even up a
lot of this stuff like this individual
at the end is just wrecking us and he's
doing a great job and it's because the
power-ups are kind of even and things
out which is nice
there's a there's a four-player going on
with three of the lords and then a
younger and brand-new inaugurated lord
and he is you know considerably younger
than the other look so that those
twitter reactions are all on fleek as we
like to come so lord kognito what do you
feel about the game
the old man loving it so far definitely
twin-stick vibe feels I'm learning the
powerup aspect is actually very cool you
just got to get used to if you haven't
done twin-stick in a while I had to wipe
the rust off love it in that yo it feels
good the power-ups are fun it's a great
party game right now I'm really enjoying
it Lord hide we're gonna get you on look
how do you feel about the game actually
I was really into geometry wars when it
just came out and this reminds me a lot
of geometry war so I'm diggin it so far
geometry Wars is an interesting
comparison because again that twin-stick
feel where you have to get used to like
your movement and just controlling the
axis around your your your player
character is like I said before this
this game when we first saw it look
super polished look incredibly fun
incredibly deep in the amount of content
that's in the game and these guys has
just been working hard to try to get
this game out before the end of the
summer so once again we need to support
these type of games this is a
development this is the development crew
that's three gentlemen just three guys
working on this for a number of years
they grew up together and they decided
one day that they wanted to learn how to
program and make games and this is the
product of it so please go out and
support it's going to be out on all
major platforms when it does release
steam Xbox Playstation and of course the
switch
to his Lord sovereign signing out for
the iron Lords podcast and Lords of
gaming dotnet once again decoy games
swim sanity out later this summer
[Music]